well joining us now from Edinburgh we
can talk now to the Liberal Democrats
Home Affairs spokesperson christine
Jardine thank you very much for being on
the program this morning I just want to
start by talking about the remain
alliance between the Lib Dems and the
Green Party and plaid Comrie agreeing
that in 60 seats they're going to field
only one candidate with the other
parties standing down to give one remain
candidate about a shot at winning that
seat isn't that a bit of a kick in the
teeth for voters in these constituencies
who may very well not be able to vote
for their preferred candidate is the
chance to ensure that the the remain
movement if you like wins and as the
largest strongest party remain across
the UK the Liberal Democrats are central
to that this is simply an arrangement
for this election
because it is so important to the future
of the country certainly the most
significant election I think I can
remember in my lifetime and I think it's
important that we do have that choice on
the ballot paper a clear choice in these
areas but it is actually only 60 seats
out of 600 yeah that's not going to
really help the voters in those 60 seats
there is it and I know that you're
talking about giving people a clear
remain choice on the ballot paper but
people vote for parties for many
different reasons and there are some
pretty big policy differences between
the parties in this remain alliance I
mean my camera for example want Wales to
be independent I mean they're a Welsh
National Party that's a huge issue for
many people of Wales and yet you're
saying that brexit trumps everything
well actually it does because the future
of this country depends on how we handle
Briggs it only if we can stop Briggs it
can be then go on to handle things like
climate change tack up tropic climate
change invest in the NHS do something
about the terrible skill-shot is a lack
of nurses in the NHS at the moment the
lack of staff and other areas then we
have to tackle these things but before
we do we have to stop Briggs up because
it's sucking the lifeblood of everything
in this country and has done for
three-and-a-half so that is quite we
think it's important we give the voices
that clear choice giving voters a fair
choice and is an interesting way of
putting it because some people would
argue but that's not what the Lib Dems
are planning on doing I have through the
remaining lines which is a clear attempt
to try and help some candidates win
above others perhaps the Conservative
Party would argue that's a misleading
that that's something that you're trying
to do but also see referendum that many
people feel that they had a chance to
vote in they sent a clear message and
it's politicians like the Lib Dems who
are trying to overturn that democracy
this is about working together with
people we have said that we have
prepared we have always shown that we
have prepared to work with other parties
who have a similar goal and want to see
the same sort of things as and it's not
about overturning anything it's about
giving people choice democracy is about
giving people choice continually and we
have always said that our preferred
option was to give people the final say
on the deal through a referendum now
that apparently is not know going to
happen before the deadline on January
1st so we have to give people the choice
through a general election and we are
giving them a clear choice the Liberal
Democrats under just Winston are 100
percent clear that we are for a remain
and that we want to stop braces and
these other parties we are working with
them and we're bringing in people from
the Labour Party and Conservative Party
we're joining us all the time to work
towards that clearly I'm keen to talk
about the election that's coming up of
course as well the Lib Dems expected to
make as some significant gains across
the UK as a whole and but in Scotland in
particular the SNP appeared had been
doing quite well too so in Scotland is
it more of a case that the Lib Dems
trying to hold on to the seats that you
do have rather than take
States no no we are we have been
recovering for the last two years in the
seats of use of old and there's a clear
difference between us and the SMP and
that is that we want to stay in the UK
the SMP don't and that is a big issue on
the doors in Scotland people here have
had not just seen a half years of Chios
over break that we had five years before
that of a similar better divisive
argument over independence and we really
do not want to go back there we had a
clear outcome from that and you find
that most people in Scotland they want
to stay in the European Union and I want
to stay in the United Kingdom and those
are the two things that the Liberal
Democrats stand up for so we enjoying
this look this same general election and
we are getting incredibly positive
responses on the doorsteps rate across
Scotland from people who have fed up
with the system the way it is and then
just finally the concept of in the
Labour Party have agreed to two
head-to-head debates on the BBC and ITV
during the election campaign Sky News
has an offer on the table that would be
a three-way debate including Joe Swinson
what do you want to see happen and do
you think there should be an independent
commission set up to try and determine
participation in debates ahead of
general elections well I certainly don't
think it should be up to anyone for this
party to decide whether or not they will
take part in a debate on the future of
this country I think if we have a debate
then as there have to be clear
guidelines and we have to have a choice
we have to have Liberal Democrats there
with the labour and conservative party
because there is a clear choice between
Joe Swensons Liberal Democrats in the
main and the old politics of labour and
conservative and I think it's dreadful
that they are able to see well we will
take part if we don't like you obviously
but that's not the way democracy works
in a democracy you should be prepared to
stand up there and argue your case you
should be confident of your case you
should be prepared to do it I tend to
think that perhaps they're just you know
they're just frightened of debating
jewel because she was sure that she does
offer something different a great new
future and that's what they're they're
afraid of thank you very much for being
on the program this morning